[Music]
John Locke the 17th century English
philosopher argued that private property
arose when people mix their labor with
something not yet owned by anyone else
so if in the state of nature I clear
land in the wilderness and grow crops
there i acquire a right to the land and
the crops it would be wrong for someone
else to take them away without my
consent let's see it Locke's idea helps
us think about a controversy that arises
each winter in Boston after snowstorms
in Boston many people park their cars on
the street near their homes it takes a
long time to clear a parking place from
several feet of snow imagine your
frustration
if after spending hours digging out your
car you drive to the grocery store and
return to find another car parked in the
spot you dug out to prevent this people
who labor to clear snow from parking
spots install markers such as traffic
cones or lawn chairs to lay claim to
them at least for a few days should this
be permitted or should anyone be free to
use a public parking spot even if
someone else has labored long and hard
to clear it
[Music]